for a deeper look at the government
shutdown and what it means we're joined
by CBS news political correspondent ed
O'Keefe Ed's on Capitol Hill ed good
morning good morning guys how long is
this standoff like little as dead
good question Anthony you know the
Senate will reconvene later today if we
don't hear about significant progress
between congressional leaders in the
White House by dinnertime tonight I
think we're looking at a situation that
probably continues up until and perhaps
just beyond New Year's Day and it's at
that point that I think most Americans
will really start to take notice look
most people are traveling they're
focused on baking cookies today getting
the Grandma's house for Christmas
they're not necessarily paying attention
to this especially if the Santa tracker
is still on if they yeah but we're gonna
see here by the end of today probably
congressionally to say okay everybody go
home cool off come back here starting to
26th and maybe then we can figure out
something but if we hear later this
afternoon perhaps that there is a deal
great maybe they get it done by tomorrow
had the Senate unanimously approved this
and the president just just shut it down
he just said no way so is this really an
effective way to govern yeah what what
the Senate had done earlier this week
essentially was say we can continue this
fight in February let's just keep
everything open continue funding
government operations at a certain level
the president said no I want that five
billion dollars I've been asking for is
this an effective way to govern that's a
question I think that really can't be
answered until this is over and we see
how long it runs out and who ultimately
gets the blame we've this is the third
shutdown this calendar year the fourth
since House Republicans took control of
the House of Representatives back in
2011 so you know it has happened in the
last few years and yet people haven't
necessarily suffered political
consequences because of these showdown
so while this is a fight that the
president has clearly been been asking
for has tweeted about has said that he
think could be good for the system we'll
see whether he takes the blame or
whether his last minute pushed here to
put it on the Democrats succeeds and
along those lines is there any sense of
who is
getting that kind of blame we've we have
the president in his own words actually
saying that he will take the blame for
all of this from that meeting that he
had with Schumer and Pelosi about a week
ago yeah yeah the most frustrating parts
of these situations is that they spend
the first few hours maybe days blaming
each other right and trying to establish
who exactly is at fault and then they
try to clean up the mess and put it all
back together again we're in the midst
of that right now overnight Democrats
repeatedly saying it is the Trump shut
down that video right there of the
president saying he would take the blame
for it will be on a loop if Democrats
have any say in all of this course the
president now trying to say it is the
Democrats fault the reason he can say
that is that in the Senate remember you
need 60 votes to get something through
of this magnitude they don't have that
right now you require a bipartisan deal
there are no Democrats who want to sign
up for a five billion dollar border wall
deal there are several Republicans who
are skeptical of it as well and
meanwhile ed that the Democrats take
control of the house in the new year
right and the dynamics Anthony will
change this is important for people to
realize the longer this goes the more
the influence of House Republicans
diminishes and if this goes beyond
January second here's the thing come
January 3rd Nancy Pelosi and the House
Democrats have to write new spending
legislation to reopen the government
because the current congressional
session will have expired now with their
power they'll be able to write the bill
that says let's put things back together
again they'll have to cut the deal with
Republicans in the Senate and the White
House or the dynamics here over the
course of this if it runs a long while
we'll begin to shift and more of the
emphasis more of the influence on this
will go over to House Democrats and
certainly add no guarantee that
President Trump will like what he
received exactly thank you so much